so I came to tell you guys about this
really special gift that I have a gift
where people I've just met tell me
everything about their sex life
they jump right into their sexual
fantasies or what age they lost their
virginity or if you're from the
conservative South you might divulge to
me that your first vibrator was
purchased illegally in Texas
America I'm not a sex therapist I'm an
entrepreneur who's been selling sex in
Silicon Valley for four years and it has
totally changed my life
this major shift in my career happened
where all of life's major changes happen
the psychic Nicole knows what I'm
talking about I
had gone through a really bad breakup
and I hadn't gone on a date in two years
and 'va being honest I said no to most
other things in life to
this psychic had the audacity to tell me
that I was a habitual left Swiper
she made me promise that for an entire
month
I would swipe right on everyone and
granted they weren't a total creep in
the DM I would also agree to a first
date
there's a lot of weird people on tinder
you guys
but I did it and by getting into the
swing of habitual right swiping in my
dating life I started saying yes to
other parts of my life too and hence how
even though I thought taking a job at a
vibrator company would ruin my career in
consumer marketing I did it anyway I
entered the adult industry and probably
the most softcore way you can
ecommerce I
didn't have to worry about being on
camera tech conventions were more
applicable than the adult film star
Awards and a blazer was encouraged over
a g-string
my first day at Jimmy Jane my boss the
super handsome CEO with a ton of success
in Silicon Valley look straight into my
eyes and says the word
clitoris
and later
anal beads
and eventually
conquering i
sat there feeling like I was going to
cry slash die laughing slash get fired
house x-ray companies don't have more HR
problems by the way is still the biggest
unanswered question in my life
later that day I jump into an Hoover to
head home and I'm literally praying that
this 60-year old man does not ask what
type of building missus he did for fear
I would have to tell a stranger I work
at a sex toy company which I did the
conversation went exactly like this
this is such an interesting building
what type of building is this
work office oh yeah what type of work do
you do I
uh
sell stuff online oh
yeah my nephew sells stuff on Craigslist
it's so interesting what type of stuff
do you sell
vibrators I sell vibrators okay
but I got the hang of it I
started telling everyone that I worked
at a vibrator company it was like this
super awesome party trick where instead
of the typical so where are you from I
would just tell them about my job and
they would start telling me about that
one-night stand or how our form to
vibrator was so much better than their
boyfriend
I
made deeper connections faster with more
people talking about sex than I had in
my entire life before I knew it I was
running around town sharing stories
about that trip to the dildo factory or
have that super new super professional
photo on LinkedIn was actually shot in a
porn studio
that said it wasn't all orgasmic there
were times it was awkward and super
painful I remember being in an airport
waiting for my flight sitting on the
fetish page of our website frantically
fixing a loading issue when suddenly I
realized the people around me were
whispering and just kind of backing away
and then there's the time that a friend
called to tell me that my former boss a
woman who I loved and looked up to as a
mentor was telling my former colleagues
that I quit to go do porn I
was heartbroken and pre-six sex toy me
would have stopped talking about my job
publicly but post sext way me was like
you lady I am the only woman
working at this company and I'm doing it
with morals and respect
and morals and respect are incredibly
important as you can imagine the adult
category is heavily dominated by men who
sleep with their wives friends the girls
they hire for their videos their
employees basically any woman ever right
right away I had to set boundaries I
politely declined dinner invitations I
never drink at work events I refuse to
go to adult conventions and I straight
up walked out of meetings that didn't
align with my values for example
when Bruce Jenner first came out as
Caitlyn i sat on the phone with the
creative team as they proposed a blow-up
doll with highly offensive copy on the
box I hung up on them and took the next
day off I'm probably known I'm
definitely known as the most boring
person in the adult category but I sleep
just fine
speaking of sleeping Hawking vibes led
me to my first threesome
the people I met through working in at
Jimmy Jane was an unexpected benefit my
friend called me one day and said I met
this girl she's doing this other vagina
thing he doesn't to be perfect for each
other
Loren Schulte was just starting the Flex
company and was looking for a partner
with a background in e-commerce and
experience selling taboo goods I just
happened to have both I joined the
company as a co-founder along with our
third partner pan-pan for the record
we've never had sex but if I'm being
totally honest they have because they're
engaged
our first product flex is a new period
product that replaces tampons pads and
menstrual cups it's wearable up to 12
hours it's not linked to TSS and it
actually helps to relieve cramping if
that's not enough for you you can also
wear it for mess free period sex because
if there's anything sexier than sex its
period sex am i right
that's what investors thought too when
they gave us four million dollars in
venture capital to continue growing our
business into what it is today a
[Applause]
multi-million dollar consumer brand
leading innovation in feminine care by
women for women and
so even though I've moved from selling
vibrators to period products the sex
that I'm selling is not that different
because masturbation and menstruation
are actually quite similar
masturbation is this incredibly awkward
thing that everyone does and no one
talks about where the entire time you're
praying that your roommate doesn't hear
or worse walk in on you the same is true
with menstruation menstruation is
equally awkward everyone does it no one
talks about it and the entire time
you're praying that your coworker
doesn't see you shoving a tampon up your
sleeve when you walk to the bathroom to
change it or worse walk in on you
both come down to a total lack of
education so now instead of answering
customer inquiries about what size Kegel
will fit or to quote Eminem what a
woman's clitoris is I spend my time
talking to anyone and everyone about the
female anatomy how women's health
deserves to be in the hands of women
why period sex is safe and enjoyable and
how if a man offers you a job and a
vibrator in public at the Ferry Building
in San Francisco it might be worth
saying yes to
[Applause]